[Music]
Mr. Jéré, hello. I'm contacting you
today for a website
called serw. I'd like to get your
perspective on Prism and its repercussions
on democracy.
Steller,
the revelations about the
Prism affair are interesting for several reasons. First,
because we now have
irrefutable proof of this surveillance and
its massive, widespread nature.
For 10 years, we collected evidence,
testimonies, and information, some more
promising than others. Today,
a document marked "Top Secret"
is the irrefutable proof: this figure of
97 billion pieces of information
for just the month of March
2013. For 10 years, I was called a
conspiracy theorist. Today, we know it's
the truth. But this is
the essential element to be able to
start a public debate on the subject
of mass surveillance and
perhaps hope to reverse
this ultra-security and
paranoid spiral.  by the United States and arms
manufacturers following
September 11, 2001, so that's the first
element. The second element is that we
now have irrefutable proof of the
participation of web giants like Google,
Facebook, Apple, Skype, and so on in
this mass surveillance. This
proves once again, beyond a shadow of a doubt, that
we cannot trust these
companies to
protect our privacy, our personal data
and communications, or
our fundamental freedoms in the
broadest sense, even if we
fully understand the terms and
conditions of
these services. In the middle, there's a huge
black hole: American law, the
FISA (Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act), and the
2008 amendment, which explicitly states that when it comes to data on
non-US citizens
stored on US servers,
intelligence services can access it for any
reason whatsoever, without
asking anyone. I'll
cut you off. Do you think that
French legislators, our
politicians, are
intellectually equipped or
sufficiently trained to understand what is happening?  The
game is on, wait for a
point before that because we forget to
mention it when we talk amongst ourselves.
Why is it essential to protect
our privacy? It sounds like a
cliché to those who are used to
these concepts. You have to see that the
protection of privacy is a
fundamental freedom here in Europe.
Why is it important? Because the
protection of
privacy implies the implementation
of other freedoms. Without the protection of
privacy, we cannot effectively
exercise other freedoms, such as the
freedom of
assembly, the freedom of
movement, or simply the freedom
of expression. If you know there's
always someone looking over your
shoulder when you type, you're not going to
say, "Hey, the government is messing things up,"
or "I saw this information that
seems suspicious," or "Should we dig
into the finances of this
or that organization?" in the same way.
Perhaps not a meeting of a
political party or any group whatsoever,
if you know that the public or
anyone else might find out.
So, regarding the protection of
privacy, I would say that...  It's a
fundamental freedom, perhaps even more
fundamental than others, alongside
freedom of expression, because both
are essential components
not only of democracy but
also of the exercise of all other
freedoms. So, we have a real
societal challenge here. To answer your
question, are governments and
politicians equipped
to understand this? I would say no,
because we ourselves can't. No
one is capable of understanding how
a computer works
today, partly because the
computers we carry in our pockets, with
their baseband processors, are completely
closed. We don't have access to the
specifications, so we can't
control them. These are the
essential chips that transmit and receive
signals, whether voice or
data. So, no one today is
able to say how a
computer works. And even if we were to
invest the millions of euros
necessary to understand how
these chips work, their operation could change from one
second to the next.
Therefore, we are
not capable of understanding how
computers work in the same
way that we are unable to  To understand
how the internet works, we can
learn bits and pieces,
try to understand as much as
possible, obviously with one goal in mind. We can
understand how TCP/IP works, how
BGP routing works, how
bandwidth deals are made, and so on,
but understanding the entirety of the
technological and human interactions
that we call the internet is something
that, by definition, surpasses our
understanding. So when we see
conflicts between diverse interests—
whether
industrial, political,
or the general interest—on one side, arms
dealers who will, oh dear,
terrorists, and this, that, that,
possibly intertwined
with, not intertwined with, associations,
organizations,
excuse me, institutions like the NSA or
the military, or things like that, how
can we imagine that a politician will be
able to say, "No, no,
wait, the general interest is the
defense of fundamental freedoms. A
fundamental freedom is the defense of
privacy," and there's a
conflict there; it's impossible. So we're
in a power struggle that is
political by nature, and when we say "
political," alas, we're often a...  It's a little
outside the realm of rationality, where it's
not simply a matter of understanding the
issues and applying the solutions that
seem optimal, but rather a power struggle. This
power struggle pits
citizens of the world
against arms dealers and
certain members of the US administration, as well as
certain members of the administration
in
European governments. So it's truly a
political power struggle that's going quite badly for
us.
Why? Because everything has been
perfectly planned and implemented. There's
this book by Naomi Klein
called "The Shot Doctrine: The
Strategy of the Shot," which explains very
well how to use
emotional shocks in public opinion to
impose measures that would otherwise be
unjustifiable and
unacceptable. This strategy is
perfectly mastered by the
communications experts who advise
politicians and has been implemented
regularly, step by step, since
September 11, 2001, to
solidify a
security-based approach. Going back will
be extremely difficult. The
economic situation is becoming strained
globally, people are revolting, and what we've
called  The
Jasmine Spring, the Arab Spring—all these
terms are used to describe a
people rising up because they have
nothing left to eat, because a corrupt state
is at their head. Don't you think that
the intelligence services, backing a
corrupt power with lobbyists and all the
trappings that go with it, aren't they just another
way
of having a security apparatus
to control a population through
a difficult period of
economic globalization? That is, doing data
mining to identify
protest movements. Of course, if
surveillance equals control, we've seen it
everywhere in history. It's the
history of esotericism, it's
the history of secret police.
In all authoritarian regimes,
individuals are monitored not for
pleasure, but to better
control them. And that's a
classic: the day you enter
politics, you start to rebel,
you start to challenge
the established order, the government, and there  Imagine
two people knocking on your door saying, "Do
you really want us to expose
such and such aspects of your
private life to the public? Then shut your
mouth." That's generally the first step
before resorting to physical violence.
So it's going to be complicated to get involved in
politics and uphold values ​​for
our generation. It's going to be complicated for
anyone to enter politics. Yes,
we're already seeing this today, at
this stage, with reports coming out a few
days ago showing that one
in ten young people has already been refused a job
because of their
Facebook profile. So you can imagine being
refused a job; it's not
something very
exceptional, it's commonplace.
So imagine when one of these
young people tries to get into politics. In a way,
I don't want to
advocate for post-
privacy theories because I think that's nonsense,
but in a way,
in 10 years,
when people say to you, "Yeah, but you're having
an extramarital affair," or "Yeah, but
you have..."  Smoked a joint, yeah, but this and
that, these things will be much more
accepted, I think, as people
voluntarily spread this kind
of information. And at the same time, what
we're doing
is a kind of global reflection
on universal values.
When I say "we," I mean the internet,
somewhere without a boss, without a leader, without a
party, without anything. We see on one side that there are
technologies that liberate, that
are based on the sharing of
knowledge, on openness, and on
the universality of the potential for
participation. On the other side, there are
technologies that control,
technologies that monitor, that are
based on centralization and closure. And the
values ​​that
we're promoting—and here I'm going to speak as a
spokesperson for La Quadrature
du Net—when we promote these values ​​of
defending fundamental freedoms, we
promote these values ​​of sharing
knowledge, it's something that
resonates beyond borders,
beyond the limits between
political parties. And perhaps this objective—
I think it's a
societal objective—is something that  Perhaps its universal nature
is something that, in the end,
will be stronger and
will prevail over what is
ultimately just the sum of
particular interests, sectoral interests. Yes, the
sale of guns—well, these days
we don't sell guns anymore, but weapons
of mass surveillance. Yes, these are
very large contracts, they're Amesis,
BLU, and things like that.
Yes, these are enormous contracts. Yes, in the
United States, the defense budget is,
I don't know what, what
disproportionate percentage of the overall budget. It
employs, I don't know how many,
hundreds of thousands of people, and so on.
But it remains a
sectoral interest, a particular interest. What we are
defending, on the other hand, is a model
of society, the common good, and
universal values, which are
democratic values. We'll
talk about democratic values. In France,
whistleblowers are not protected, or
very little, except fiscally speaking,
like when a kid works at the
NSA or in the military...  If it's leaked
to the United States, he finds himself tortured
with the entire CIA manual that can
be applied to him:
sensory deprivation and such.
How do you find
France's position regarding what
happened? I'll take the case of Bradley Manning.
Why hasn't France spoken out
internationally to say, "You
torture in the name of freedom"? The
case of whistleblowers in
the United States is
extremely worrying. The
Obama administration attacked more whistleblowers,
I think all
previous administrations did. It's not just
Bradley Manning and poor Edward
Snowden who risk suffering a
similar fate. There's Jeln Radak, there's
Thomas Drake, there's Bill Byrd, there are
all those we haven't been able to talk about for a long time,
all those on whom the pressure
was effective before the information
leaked, all those who couldn't go so far as to
become
public to be protected by that
publicity. It's
something extremely...  This is
worrying, as we see the
power dynamic emerging
around information. We know
that information is power,
and at the same time, we see that
governments, especially the
US government, are increasingly using secrecy
to hide actions that are
either lies or
crimes. So, on one hand, there's this
inflation of secrecy, and on the other,
citizens who have the
power to expose the truth. We
see that the US government is in an
untenable situation. I believe there are 1.4
million people in the United States with
top-secret clearance, and we saw that
with the Snowden affair. Snowden didn't work
for the CIA, but for Allen
Hamilton, who contracted for the CIA. We
remember the strategies of the HBGAR,
Rin, the PAL, and this is a myriad of hundreds, if not
thousands,
of private organizations that share
this information. So, all content from
Google, Facebook, and so on, with, of course, what that
implies, especially
for
national security and defense.  that
little guys at these small companies
that can go bankrupt overnight
are 10 times
more likely to go and resell
stuff to foreign powers than
people who are at the heart of the
state apparatus, and then these people
are more inclined to reveal what they
see. I dare to hope that Edward Snowden
and others will inspire people all over the
world in these kinds
of institutions, whether public
or private, to reveal information
to try to stem this inflation
of secrecy and this
techno-totalitarian drift. Uh, are you
afraid for your
safety? No, because there are things
I gave up on a long time ago, like
going to the United States. Uh, I don't go to the United States anymore. Well, the short
story is, the second-to-last time I went there,
just before the door of my
plane, literally right in front of the door of
my plane, three FBI agents came to
ask me questions about WikiLeaks. They
wanted information on how WikiLeaks
works. I wanted to
become an informant because  I
'm friends with Julian, so I
resisted their pressure pretty well. They even went so far as to... what?
I said, "Listen, I defend
ideas, as you know, so that means going
to prison." They said, "
Arrest me!" They finally let me
go, and it was only afterward that I
realized their entire
intervention against me was completely
illegal. They didn't show me a badge, they didn't
give me their name, they didn't
even give me their real email address
when they wanted me to contact them—
a fake address at
aho.com. And that shows the state of
decay of
American institutions and how giving them
power beyond citizen control,
beyond democratic values,
leads to results that are
completely contrary to the values ​​of
the Constitution, which are supposed to defend them.
So, for me, my personal safety... there are
things I've given up, just as at
one point
I had to become a "public figure,"
in quotes, by choosing to
become a spokesperson for something. That
means...  To say that, well, I do
interviews, people take pictures of me, they quote me
when I speak, and things like that,
so it's giving up a part of
my private life to defend a cause.
But I think that in the same way, there are
things in terms of security
where you can't spend your time
regenerating keys, doing
fresh installs, checking the fingerprints
of different BIOS chips.
Anyway, we couldn't because we do
n't have the
tools. So there comes a point where you have to
give up. I'm not saying I have
nothing to hide, but I have very few
secrets, and most of what I do
is public. You're talking about
institutions. I still have a few
questions, but I'd just like to add
something on that: I'm
certainly not comparing myself to these
whistleblowers who perform
acts of courage that
surpass all of us. We see when
Snowden speaks; he knows he's risking his
life, that he might never see his
house, his family, and so on, which puts
even  His family by doing this,
but he
says I have to do it.
Uh, I think deep down we all have
this spark of
freedom, this sense of justice, this
humanity, Bens, which can push us one
day to say, from a personal point of view,
it's really not a good idea, but
I have to do it, and I'm going to do it anyway. And that's
courage, and that's what
WikiLeaks was saying, saying
courage is contagious. Courage is contagious. I
hope that's true. I think it's
the only solution to get out of
this situation. Two quick questions:
first, the
Jean-Marie El report, which is heavily focused on
Chinese servers.
Cisco servers have been screwing us over for about thirty
years. What do you think about that? Do
you think he lacked
courage? Go ahead, continue. Well, I have
n't read it from cover to cover,
so I'd have a hard time
speaking from experience. I
could refer
to previous
parliamentary reports, like the Labord report.
There was also a report  Carayon's presentation on
economic intelligence was
quite well-crafted and already touched on the
issue of
trusting
closed technologies. It's not compatible with
democracy, nor
with simply controlling these
information systems. So whether we're
talking about Apple or Microsoft's closed software, the
closed chip specifications of Cisco, ZTE, or Huawei routers,
or the basebands inside
phones, that's a
huge question. I don't know if
Bokel touched on this, but the
problem is the same:
we outsource trust in the
core of our
communication infrastructure to companies that
respond to other
imperatives and objectives than
defending the
personal,
sensitive, and critical communications of
French citizens and institutions. In France, we have
a real problem. On the other hand,
I know we have a pool of talent that's
far from negligible. For example,
in Lancy, I imagine they must be
considering the question of
computers.  Pocket phones, and
their relationship to communication waves,
remote activation, and things like
that—Linc's work on
technologies that concern the general
public should, by default, be published as
free software. What's missing here is
an industrial policy
that would articulate, on the one hand,
computer security research
conducted with state resources, like at ANAC,
and on the other hand,
public policy objectives, which are to
give citizens tools
allowing them to regain control of
their information and
communication, namely
decentralized free-service software and point-to-
point encryption. All of this should be articulated
around a somewhat industrial policy.
I don't know if it's
Montebourg who needs a good shake-up
or Jean-Marc H directly, but
tell them, "Hey guys, throw a few
million euros at them to
fund free software projects
that meet these criteria." It's
not more complicated than that. The
talent is already there, the projects
already exist, you just need to... you just need to
water them. There's not even any need to plant
seeds in the ground, you just need to...
water them. Last question: if you had
one piece of advice for future generations,
one piece of advice for the young people listening to us, uh,
speaking, leave them a message in a bottle
on the internet and give them... One piece of advice: it's a huge
responsibility to learn to code to
learn how
computers and
information systems work in
general. I think it's about as
essential as knowing how to read,
write, and do arithmetic today, and not
coding in some visual Smurf thing,
but doing algorithms, talking
to the
machine,
reading, and...
Three, to draw the following conclusions:
the defense of freedoms is
not something abstract, it is not
something
distant, and even less
something over which we have
no control, but it is something very
real and over which we have an
influence every day through the choices
we make;
and that the question, ultimately, is what kind of
world we want to bequeath to the
next generation, and that
now everything is in their hands.
Cherimerman,
thank you very much, your questions are great, yeah.